有很多物体
很多材料
很多几何图形
我们经常面临克服CPU瓶颈的挑战
然后嗯
但是这种
你知道吗
已经解决了
今年我们将更多地研究GPU瓶颈
专注于改进整个系统，而不是调整单个着色器
尽管我们会提到一些关于如何编写更有效的着色器的技巧
并概述硬件体系结构实际上是如何工作的
并实现图形流水线
所以如果我们回头看
你知道的
在GPU的黎明
我们有很好的老GL开始
它的速度足够快，可以将每个顶点单独推入图形硬件
随着场景复杂度的增加
你知道最终不再有效率了
所以CPU成了GPU的瓶颈
Gpus一年比一年快
幸运的是
如果我们看看现在
我们有现代API
我们在渲染中有数据驱动的设计
所以如果我们看看OpenGL
我们有多张间接的
我们有英伟达无纺技术
我们有命令列表扩展，它为我们提供了非常非常高效的CPU呈现方法
嗯
大场面
你知道在很短的CPU时间内有很多命令
我们实际上有了一个全新的API
那只是
你知道
真的是围绕着
在CPU上提高效率
利用许多核心等等
那么未来是什么
理想情况下，当GPU变得更加可编程时
不仅仅是在阴影上
也在整个决策中
所以用多平局间接
我们有这样的方式，GPU如何创建自己的Draw调用
当我们扩展这个概念时，或者你知道这个概念
我们可以做更有趣的效果
就像比我们以前更好的遮挡剔除
我们可以在GPU上做动态级别的细节决策
如果我们看看这些球体
所以绿色的会用自适应的镶嵌来渲染
在青色的上面有
你知道的
只是简单的网格
背景上有一些红点
就是点精灵
所以所有这些级别的详细决策都是由GPU自己完成的
我们也可以直接在GPU上驱动动画
你知道
通过拥有一切来最大限度地减少延迟
所有的决策
管道中的所有计算
理想情况下，芯片上也有数据
我们甚至可以做完全疯狂的新事情
你知道我们不必拘泥于经典的三角光栅化
我们可以做
比如说
在这个距离场渲染是由ego illas完成的嗯
所以这一切都是由遥远的领域组成的
在像素着色器中的光线跟踪距离字段上跟踪光线
所以你知道这里没有三角形进化
显示了你所知道的
你今天可以呈现的疯狂方式
这就引出了一个问题
你知道的
我们实际上如何很好地利用硬件
这就引出了下一个问题
当涉及到图形时，硬件实际上是如何工作的
这就是为什么在这次演讲中
我们将介绍一点关于硬件设计的概述
当谈到图形时
我们将经历一个三角形的生命
所以从你知道
从API发送到帧缓冲区内存中的某个像素
并最终显示出一些实际的后果
那么作为一个图形程序员，这对你来说到底意味着什么
当你在编写OpenGL时
或者欢迎
我把它给皮埃尔
他是硬件架构专家
和软件
在上面和右边
你可以看到我们去年推出的一个硬件的示意图
这是一颗宝石两百
嗯
所以你可以看到你在单位中有很多重复
所以梯度中的是可编程单元
然后在顶部和底部你有一些其他的单位
更固定的功能让我们可以把数据输入引擎程序
所以这幅画的有趣之处在于你有很多不同的单元
很明显，Cuda核心是最常见的
但是你有你有六个几何集群
我是说全球定位系统
然后我们有一些光栅输出单元
它可以做颜色和混合
我们有很多单位
图片的有趣之处在于当你做图形的时候
每一个周期通常需要
如果一个单位没有工作要做
那么这个单元就不做功了
所以你失去了效率
所以它不应该利用硬件
你必须查看整个系统
说我能用很多这样的单位吗
所有人同时
如果你
如果你只是在某个地方限制一个单位
然后每个人都在等那个
那你显然做得不好
所以当我们在内部查看应用程序时
我们看着
呃
发生什么事了？
我们看到一系列的政权
这不是真的像
你知道的
硬件只是随机地做一些事情
我们看到了，或者你需要渲染到阴影地图
你确实喜欢深度预演
或者你确实喜欢一些电脑更新更多
你的矩阵
我们把这些看作序列
序列的数量也没有那么多
你知道取决于应用程序可能不是少数
可能有几十个
最多可能有一百个
但它真的是有限数量的序列
在每一个序列中
我们倾向于看到你会被一个单位限制
可能是两个单位
这真的成为了那个序列的瓶颈
如果你看一个框架
然后你有一系列的步骤
每一步都受到一些单位的限制
所以如果你想提高正在发生的事情的效率
你得看个人的步骤
并努力确保你能很好地分配工作
在那一步里
从长远来看，这真的已经持续了很长一段时间
但是嗯
我们正在努力增加芯片的概率
这意味着你可以分散步行
你是怎么做的
只是依赖于任何API定义的渲染，就像
哦
让我们用函数着色推多边形
这是一个永远不会停止的趋势
我们
我们有人喜欢在它们中设计新的功能，使它们更通用
并随着时间的推移消除限制
所以今天图形中的固定功能单元在传统的图形流水线中
嗯类似的
今天的一个关键功能是帮助您扩展和减少数据
所以你从一个平局开始
可以是1到n个原语
但你从一个平局开始
可能是一万个原始人
然后你要处理它们
他们中的一些人会被淘汰
它们中的一些实际上会形成一个可见的三角形，你可以处理
每个三角形可以是几个像素
或者一个三角形可能是一百万像素
所以真的有很多放大和缩小
这是通过固定的功能来管理的
所以总的来说，因为膨胀和缩小的数据
它不是
嗯
在一个通用中做所有的事情是没有效率的
就像SM和Lu
如果你知道你可以做很多光栅化
你有固定的质量，你可以做到这一点
然后你知道你可以创建一个固定的函数
所以你必须看到这些功能单元对你来说就像免费资源
以提高系统的效率
另一方面
如果你知道这是你现在唯一使用的东西
那么你可以说，而不是像依赖
你实际上可以开始有像
更聪明和新的阴影实际上喜欢卸载
并减少工作量
最佳范例
如果你做顶点获取
如果你得到了能力，你得到了很多
这就成了瓶颈
那么也许您实际上可以使用更严格的格式
或者做一些压缩
然后在纹理中用一些指令压缩它们
我的意思是典型的是一个正常的，你可以做一个
只要发送x y，因为z
如果你想
和那些固定的功能单元，我们在硬件中，实际上甚至问题
一个随着时间的推移
他们我们改变他们的数量
取决于实际工作量和嗯
和产品细分
所以手越高，我们往往什么都有
低端我们只是开始砍掉单位
好的
那么我们如何实际分配工作
所以通常你从
一些进来的工作
你知道它会排队
在下面的单元中
只要工作要做
我们只是处理它，在这种情况下，假设我们有顶点进来
我们有另一个单位刚刚收集三角形
然后它进入了
就像光栅化器和光栅化器，只是那些三角形
所以我们有两个独立的世界队列进入这些单元
然后这两个
顶点和像素将分布到MS中
然后我们有一个常见的队列
我们将管理这两者之间的负载平衡
所以当你有很多工作要做的时候
然后底部的单元我们只施加反压
你说
我很忙
我四岁
我再也受不了了
顶部的所有单元我们开始做有用的工作
因为所有单元之间的FIFO或工作队列都很忙
今天所有这些工作队列都是由某人在硬件中管理的
被我们
所以我提到了随着时间的推移，我们有政权，政权之间会发生什么
这真的取决于什么样的过渡
你可以申请
最简单的是说
好的
我受够了
现在停止芯片，做点别的
我们称之为等待GPU空闲
这对性能真的很不利
正如你所看到的
嗯
比如说在左边
你有买家了
你开始爬升
走到芯片有所有这五个满和忙
那就是芯片做得不好
因为数以百万计的单位只是等待和开始工作
所以左上角的利用率很低
然后芯片是忙的是四，实际上是像做事情一样
然后你说住手
然后一段时间也跑下来
所以这两个时间是不对称的
也许他们看起来很对称
第一部分是基于延迟
真正开始产生工作
我稍后会讨论这个问题
公羊倒下了
这实际上取决于完成当前任务需要多长时间
所以如果你有一个像素需要十万个循环
这需要一个循环
实际经历的无尺寸循环
所以这真的需要很长时间
所以你可能会因为停止芯片而损失很多利用率
所以真的有一个障碍
你在启动时支付两倍的成本
在最后
所以你必须确保你不做
你不要经常阻止作弊
这些可能会发生是因为两个原因
其中一个在现代API中
你实际上可以控制，你可以说，就像你知道的GL记忆障碍
也可以在呈现中创建依赖项
佩林
Vulkan
或者有时它们可以是内部的
或者我们知道你不能重做的司机
我们必须阻止它
所以我们就像我们会
我们将显式和隐式地插入一个
在这些情况下
所以我已经说过了，比如坡道时间
我已经谈到了潜伏期
并且GPU具有很高的吞吐量
我们做的关键事情之一是尝试高延迟的操作
所以你有执行单位
所以rms非常接近一个文件
那就是我们
我们很快就把它弄出来了
嗯，但是如果你没有足够的寄存器
然后我们开始溢出到L一个
或者如果你让记忆像
如果您将内存访问作为一个
你可能会经历0和1
所以到达那里需要更长的时间
而且潜伏期更高
然后它就不适合L的了
你得去L 2
如果她不适合那里
我也是
然后归零
我是说这需要很长时间
从一套到另一套需要多长时间
它真的是不同的，从我们的平衡，就像在芯片之间和代际之间
嗯
但它可能会很长，我给你一些数字
不要被实际的数字所困扰
它更像是你必须考虑的钱
但假设你开始说
你在CPU上什么都没有，然后说
好的
去做一些工作的时候
硬件就像信号一样
就像从美国来的
做一些工作
它将开始从系统内存中获取这些命令
让我们来看看PCA潜伏期
那是成千上万个循环
只是为了得到第一个进来的
但很明显，就像同时出现多个问题一样
所以我们试图掩盖这个潜伏期
但是第一个像
你能说做一件事至少要花一千个周期吗
在GPC之前，就像任何东西的第一个命令一样
一旦我们完全控制
那么我们就有了为之奋斗的理由
所以我们可以在
你知道一点钟似乎很合理
有些需要更长的时间
他们中的一些人可能更快
如果我们喜欢超级聪明
但每时每刻都没有人
就好像
你知道吗
你能想到的平均值的合理数字
然后你有一个顶点着色器
着色器
我们取顶点
需要多长时间
你知道这取决于你的顶点数据是否被缓存
但是想想像
你知道几百个循环
三和路
就像
你知道你有很多属性
比那个长得多
如果分散对内存的访问
需要更长的时间
但你知道，似乎是为了一些简单的情况，这很好
一个转变需要多长时间
那就更多了
你知道就像你知道
只是为了在你的MV模型之间发布几个点乘积
V度量和预测以及一个新的位置
你知道这是几百个循环
所以这不是
它实际上比仅仅获取数据更快
所以你可以想到
你知道双重转换是免费的
耗时最长的实际上是获取数据以覆盖延迟
像素着色器
做一个触摸效果需要多长时间
这取决于你是否在缓存中
可能有一百个大约一百个循环
如果它没有击中
那么也许因为两个和你可以拿200
那里不热
然后你就归零了
可能是五百
可能比这还要多
我是说
如果DRAM真的忙于调色
你应该在一个内存通道上接受请求
那你知道我们得等前面的工作完成
打开新页面
所以也可能需要相当长的时间
所以它真的要本地化到你的内存子系统
这真的是获得良好表现的关键
一般来说
我们试图掩盖事情的潜伏期
所以当你在一个像素里
你做纹理操作
嗯
你知道，如果你做了纹理提取，但没有回来
我们就干点别的，做些有用的工作
但如果你所做的一切都是一千个周期的延迟
那么掩盖这个潜伏期就比
只是如果所有的东西都是一个纹理热
好的
让我们来看看一个简单的三角形会发生什么
所以在圆周率水平上，你说
好的
你得画那些三角形
API真的发生在司机身上
也就是
你知道的
我们编写的CPU代码
当你安装驱动程序时
然后我们在内存中写入一系列命令
硬件实际上来自我们所说的前端
它只是获取那些命令
它会说我们要画那些三角形
前端只是得到那些命令
他做的第一件事就是
唯一开始走路的东西
就是在机器上分发原语
正如您在第一个测试用例中所看到的
我们有很多三角形
太多了，一大块做不完
所以我们只是把大块包装成批
进入我们的翘曲
然后我们在分配完
就像三角形
那更像是我们分配的索引
说
好的
这些三角形是给你的
那些挣扎是为了你
我们要去拿贝斯了
运行顶点着色器
最终我们做了镶嵌，或者这是另一种潜在的任务分配
然后我们做一个视口处理
然后我们切换到屏幕空间
管道的一部分
第一部分是世界空间的转变
屏幕空间是关于
好的
现在我有了我的三角形
它已经被改造了
它在屏幕上
就像在屏幕空间里
我要做光栅化
然后很明显你有
因为你知道如果你真的拉屎了
你在墙壁空间里跑步
你有很多三角形
可能是
你知道它可以有一个三角形覆盖整个屏幕
你必须把它分配给多个光栅化
否则你就会保持平衡
所以我们把工作分配在那里
所以每艘巡洋舰都能看到三角形的A
影响该地区的
它负责
然后启动像素着色器
然后我们进行调色和深度操作
然后我们写入内存并进行一些压缩以减少内存流量
所以在这两者之间有一件事很有趣
当你去光栅化的时候
嗯
所以你做墙壁空间处理的第一部分
它可以在任何地方
也没有
你知道你只需要把散步切成神奇的块
没有限制
真的，一旦你开始做屏幕太空行走
然后你开始有限制
因为光栅化或拥有一块屏幕地产
这是你可以在一些照片中看到的东西
在左上角和左上角，我们有一个g力模型
我是说自己的牌
然后我们试着着色来渲染同样的东西
但不是像渲染你知道的真正的颜色
我们使用GSM I和翘曲ID
在OpenGL中内置的
好的
哪个SM处理那个像素的块
或者谁来处理它
你可以在左边看到
当你计算的时候
当你着色的时候
基于
Sid正在处理的顶点中的哪个顶点
这有点像
没有屏幕分布
它看起来没有屏幕
然后一个一旦你切换到像素着色器
大家可以看到
你知道，就像纱门按钮
它实际上是一个分布的屏幕空间
所以工作的分组
你知道在我们的情况下是三人一组
所以如果你算上
也许你会在方块的侧面找到这些数字
然后我们就不讨论太多细节了
这不是把它放在任何API中的东西
但这是一件事
你知道你
很有趣的是，这样的步行街
好的
让我们回顾一下发生了什么
第一件事
当你叫司机的时候
你可以说
好的
我想渲染一下
你知道吗
我想画那个
我已经谈过推缓冲器了
所以我们要做的是你有所有这些API参数
我们有一个数据结构
也就是
你知道一些记忆
我们把所有的参数都复制到顶部的推缓冲区上
我们放的一个东西是一个标题，上面写着
好的
那将是一个平局命令
那个标题真的是我们内在的东西
你看不到
但这是司机方面的真正代码
我告诉GPU
好的
这就是接下来发生的事情
下一步是API可以说
好的
3.我早已经告诉过你要按我说的去做
现在你要提交它
所以我们浏览这个提交列表
我们有一些信号量和幻想，我们必须管理
但关键是
我们要给指针
将缓冲区推到内核
内核会给出指向GPU的指针
所以现在GPU作为内存指针
它包含那些令牌和参数
它实际上会对它们做些什么
所以我们的前端会在pcie上分块读取内存
具有高延迟
然后它会把那些
你知道那些
不会像一个代币
不知道什么东西的大小
所以你会是大块的，试着覆盖它，看看
然后我们会开始说
好的
第一个是
哦
我抽到了一些东西
所以标题告诉你
然后有许多参数，我们用它做一些事情
我们所有的代币
我们有
抽屉或引发器
我们可以有清除
我们可以有很多东西，我们有状态
所以它实际上是一个状态序列
然后用这些状态做一些事情，做一些事情
这就是前端的作用
我们在我们的
在我们的前端实际上是当我们发送平局
我们需要确保事情做得井井有条
所以我们必须管理
就像命令和知道
好的
这一行就做好了
就像你可以用抽屉做一样
所以我知道我可以做别的事情
这样我们就可以管理操作序列
我们可以发令牌说
好的
令牌完成后告诉我
所以那个着色器
像素
着色器、混合和邀请内存
完事了再来告诉我
然后我们可以管理转换
这样做
所以就喜欢而言
如何管理状态
所以我们得到了州
有些很简单
你可以
你知道他们可以用一个周期
或者如果状态与上一个状态相同
我们有一些尝试去发现它仍然需要
也许一个循环就可以丢弃它
因为我们只需要实际阅读和观察它
但我们可以很快讨论这个
所以如果你试图达到每秒1亿次的抽奖
那你就知道
如果你有十个州
你知道这是你能做的最多的
你可以过滤
因为我们的GPU大约在1千兆赫
所以它是免费的
你知道，如果你派人去，你能做的不多
如果你像数百个州一样爆炸
每一次你永远无法达到那种程度的平局
有些状态越来越复杂
如果你做一个阴影开关
我们有
你知道我们必须知道你分配了多少寄存器
你知道有多少是纹理或像素着色器
输入泄漏是什么样子的
因此矢量和像素着色器之间的链接
这么多信息要看
还有很多单位要设置
所以可能需要更长的时间
他们也有一些
你可以马上申请
你知道当你去处理顶点的时候
你知道你可以立即设置一些东西
但有时你会有一些状态
这将在很久以后影响到埃林的其余部分
所以你不是一个好程序
你需要马上因为要编程
如果单位在做一些工作
但是这项工作有一个潜伏期
你知道一万个循环
你突然变得很便宜
所以你可能会在捆绑中回忆一些状态
这些包将被处理
当你真的需要在很久以后做这项工作的时候
所以它是一个呃的管道
托管状态
我已经谈过工作分配器了
所以实际上是管理抽签操作的单位
第一个抽到的
当你有一个索引行时
然后从下一个缓冲区收集索引
嗯，如果你没有索引
嗯嗯超级三角形
或者如果你有
你知道我们可能会在内部生成假索引
所以它是，但你可以想像
你知道我们有一个单位负责交配
指数
然后我们也可以管理那个单位
将管理我们使用的所有顶点
当你有一个独立的三角形
你知道富人的过度使用可能是六比一
所以我们不一定要变换所有的顶点
好像他们是依赖的
如果你知道你刚刚看到了
我们将努力利用这一点
然后我们创作了一批作品
我们将不得不创建一个讲座
由于有32个元素，这对我们来说是一个扭曲的工作
三十二了
所以它可以是如此的顶点线
如果你有32个顶点
你最多有
所以三角形
我的意思是
三个三角形不是你在实践中得到的
嗯
但你可以得到三分
原始的分配器也会把行走切成薄片
所以当你有多个短信和Arran在GPC中
我们会喜欢
努力分配工作，以便每个人都能工作
一旦TPC或战争在其中一个SM中产生
然后我们从工作开始做得更好
所以我们要做的第一件事就是取联邦快递
所以我们获取内存的属性
我们得打开其中一些
所以我们对流进行转换
我们可以把这些属性存储在一个
然后我们开始对这个属性进行操作的纹理
所以我们会读它们
做转化
做照明
做你影子在做的事
然后我们要把它写回L
然后我们有我们的变形引擎
实际上我们会把步行送到
到横梁上
做屏幕太空行走
所以在光栅之后，它变得非常瑞典
嗯
所以我们想创建三角形和像素
所以当我们做那些三角形的时候
我们有一些要做的高
所以我们我们不
我们想尽快拒绝像砖块一样的群体
所以呃
这是我们要做的第一件事
然后呢
一旦我们知道这个三角形真的会击中像素或样本
然后我们开始计算边缘
你知道这是取样的
还是出来了
我们创建了一个我们想要的覆盖面具
嗯嗯我们想要栅格化
我们创建两个像素的组
这是非常关键的
像常规的纹理操作
所以在我们这里的情况下
我们要创建三角形击中两个四边形
所以两个两个两个
所以底部的那个是为了顶部的那个只有一个
真的像素
但我们会创造一个二乘二的
嗯嗯
像素着色器中的组窃取
我们只是要有一个转换
天性说好
这三个人最后不会做任何事情
但我们仍然要对它们进行计算
这样我们就可以对它们做一些导数运算
嗯所以
呃
像素着色器
将在32个元素上再次运行
嗯
这就是我们今天所拥有的
嗯再次
它在API中不直接可见
除非你使用这些内置程序来知道你是哪一个
所以这个
图片将获取并润色属性
嗯，然后它会运行着色器
所以这个
就像我们之前看到的
所有标记为不用于的线程
要执行一些操作
但他们不一定做所有的记忆
i o操作
因为它们真的是死像素
你可以知道你是否真的是像素共享中的线程
通过查看在开放GL中内置的助手和职业
然后当呃
当你想做纹理操作时
你需要计算LODS
然后我们需要做一个区别，就像一个二乘两个
像那样知道
什么是导数
然后一旦像素着色器完成
然后写出一般的颜色或数据
你最终
也可以修改来自球体人的深度和覆盖范围
嗯，在着色器之后，我们进入光栅操作
包括调色和深度测试
深度测试可以在像素着色器之前进行
如果你
如果你能做早期深度拒绝
嗯和嗯
这些餐厅单元的一个关键方面是重新引入点菜
像素着色器可能会出现故障
问题操作
如果你做纹理加热
像素着色器很快就完成了
但如果你在小姐身上做手术
这些只是需要更长的时间
所以一切都可能变得无序
所以你要确保当你写信给她的时候
一切都井然有序
我们唯一有问题的时候就是你做的时候
嗯写在角落里
我们有一个机制来进行原始的混合
这些光栅输出以及它们最终将写入
另外，先前的操作通常会读操作
这个开始写操作
你有很多压缩技术
取决于深度和颜色
尽量减少内存流量
这些技术已经
我们在这些周围有一些白皮书
所以我不打算说太多细节
但他们真的看着街区
就像在屏幕空间里
试图利用
你知道一个
你知道的
我该怎么说
我不是说
所以他们把它看成一个街区
他们会说是
有足够的对称性吗
所以实际上必须有更少的压缩
所以你可以做的一件事是消除压缩
试着在这里像一个像素一样写
这里一个像素这里一个像素
因为我们真的没有一个信息块
所以效率不高
所以你把它放在所有微小的
压缩可能真的不太好用
当你原始的喜欢足够大的时候
那你就会有一大堆权利
你有足够的数据来进行压缩
麦克斯韦有爱改善压缩
它是
这是相当不错的
用那个思考
下一个是你吗
好的
有人喜欢长篇大论地谈论这个话题
所以我会
我们来不及了
但不管怎样
我们之后只是啤酒和海报会议
所以如果你不太渴的话应该没问题
所以是的
让我们看看您的程序的一些利用率和实际结果
如果你是前端有限
所以上面处理所有命令的东西
那么添加更多的命令显然是不好的
例如
更改着色器需要在命令处理器中进行多次循环
然而
如果你的着色器有限
所以你知道
像素和顶点着色器
主要是
像素着色器的利用率最高
那么添加更多命令就不成问题了
也就是说你可以
其实
你知道制作更专业的着色器是有意义的
而不是效率不高的大着色器
最终
比如屏幕分辨率等等增加了像素着色器
在巴尔干半岛占主导地位
我们在硬件概述中有这个障碍
所以在巴尔干半岛，我们有子传递，我们可以在呈现传递中定义
理想情况下，你定义这些子传球是相互独立的
这样我们就可以避免有太多这样的障碍
这样你就知道
驱动程序和硬件
一切都知道
好的
这些通行证实际上是
你知道的
他们不需要一个接一个地被处决
所以要注意这一点并利用它与副传球系统
当涉及到深度缓冲区时，也应该利用子传球
圆周率已经提到过，我们有一个分层的z剔除
所以我们在芯片上有某种中间地图链
所以芯片内存允许我们快速拒绝三角形
但是每次我们改变深度缓冲区
我们实际上需要将数据从帧缓冲区复制到芯片上
或者再回来
所以在许多深度缓冲区之间切换是不好的，因为我们付出了代价
你知道这里的额外费用
您也可以通过再次使用子通行证来避免这种情况
实际上
你知道的
交错一些根本没有使用深度缓冲区的传递
我们实际需要的深度缓冲器可以留在芯片上
如果你有这样的场景
好的
状态机的一点
幸运的是
你知道原料药进化得如此之快
在CPU端冗余状态
如果你使用像巴尔干半岛这样的现代API
或者命令列表扩展名或无绑定等等，我们可以做
我们现在可以通过API推送很多状态
所以我们可能再也看不到CPU的成本了
但我们确实在GPU上看到了它
因为即使有冗余过滤器
你知道所有这些命令都必须处理
所以在这里我们渲染了一些基本的显卡
你知道一次又一次著名的显卡
嗯
它所有的晶体管
如果您指定颜色信息
每次平局都是多余的
那么你知道这将我们的GPU时间增加了一倍
而从CPU和所有这些现代命令缓冲区和所有这些
基本上没什么
所以你知道如果你打很多很多的平局电话，这仍然很重要
当涉及到状态机时的另一个方面
我们刚刚看到绑定的影响是
尤其是在关于绑定的精确方面
在巴尔干半岛
我们必须定义我们在每个阶段使用的资源
像顶点
碎片
几何学
等等
所以你越精确
硬件实际上要做的艰苦工作就越少
因为如果你说你知道这个缓冲区在每个阶段都使用
然后你知道硬件会为每个阶段设置它
这增加了额外的成本
我们在硬件上也有两个不同的系统
一个用于推常量，一个用于常规资源绑定
理想情况下，您可以通过以下方式来平衡这些不同的系统
你知道吗
把你的高频变化放在两个系统中的任何一个
所以很明显，如果我们不做很多绑定更改
你知道这并不重要
但如果我们真的有很多平局电话
具有大量更改的小绘制调用
特别是矩阵在CAT中的应用
比如说
那就有关系了
利用这一点可能是有意义的
理想情况下
推常数只用于一个阶段
您还应该使用描述符集
管道继承
巴尔干半岛的井捆绑遗产
这有点酷
所以如果我们有一个着色器
那就是
你知道使用某个描述符集
也就是
让我们说
有一些均匀的缓冲
并且指定它在某个绑定槽中使用
下一个着色器也希望
设置在同一绑定槽上的描述符
然后指定balkan以保持该绑定的活动
所以如果这样我们可以减少绑定的数量
如果您基本上按照更改的频率来组织绑定
所以你知道
用于大多数事情的最低数字
所以它几乎没有变化
然后更高的数字变化得更频繁
这样你也可以不发送太多的命令
让我们看看实际上做一些工作
我们主要需要数据来完成这项工作
所以当我们送你知道
更新我们的缓冲区等等，我们可以更新
发送大量复制命令
但这对
你知道复制引擎和整个PCI Express设置
所以最好组织小数据
使用登台缓冲区更新自己
您有一个缓冲区在CPU内存中
你用你想要更新的数据和潜在的位置来填充它
然后你可以运行一些着色器来分散数据这样
你传输的所有数据都很紧凑，然后分散开来
如果您实际上只使用这些数据一次
就像你知道的
超动态顶点数据
或者统一的数据或其他什么
然后你可以把它留在CPU内存中
因为你知道拷贝只完成一次
一个非常特别和重要的音符
当谈到Vulkan
可以指定不同平铺格式的图像
有一个平铺线性格式
也就是
你知道对于最终用户来说
很适合上传
但是在GPU中使用真的很糟糕，在我们的硬件上性能也很差
所以您不希望将其用于实际的GPU资源
比如帧缓冲区和纹理
你只想把它用于你复制的东西
你知道的
复制源或复制目的地
如果你真的用它
另一个降低传输成本的方法显然是不发送这么多数据
只是重新计算
例如矩阵
嗯
或者你知道
任何类型的动画
您可以发送一个时间值
你可以发送这个矩阵的一些增量变化
等级制度发生了变化
然后我们重新计算剩下的
而不是一直发送所有的数据
当谈到矩阵时
我们在一些猫的应用程序中可能需要双倍
所以双打在GPU上不是超快的
我是说
取决于GPU产品
但在图形上通常不太好
但如果你没有这么多矩阵就足够了
所以做你的矩阵计算和双倍是可以的
然后你也可以在串联上做矩阵
所以相机和视图矩阵与对象矩阵
因为那是你真正需要双打的地方
因为你知道如果事情离原点很远
然后将整个矩阵存储为浮点
所以对于实际的渲染，我们总是使用float
你知道我们不希望每个顶点都经过双倍
但我们希望他们贯穿始终
好的
让我们看看前面步骤中的计算效率
比如更新矩阵或发送一点数据
然后在着色器中散射
我们实际上可能没有那么多工作
比如说
我们没有
你知道吗
十万威胁
但我们实际上只有几个
在这种情况下，硬件
你知道
有
计算有一定的启动开销
因为附加的管理功能
你会遇到障碍之类的
嗯
图形为我们提供了一个替代方案
它只是用光栅化的丢弃物禁用光栅化
然后您可以通过渲染点来处理顶点着色器
就像电脑着色器一样
所以如果你只有几个线程
你知道你可能有一些
一些逻辑
然后你用
否则您使用计算
因为你知道两者之间的转换也有一点仍然有一些相关的成本
在图形中做任何事情现在也是有益的
如果你有很多很多的威胁
那么去计算是要走的路
你的着色器也可以写
而是
你知道更简单的着色器可以写得相当不可知论
因为你只需要一些线
id
我们在Vulcan也有一些很好的功能
你知道用长矛V
和在GSL中
尤其是对于英伟达来说，在这些威胁之间共享数据
就像你记得的那样
我们在曲速中有三个两个威胁
改变我们在它们之间传递的数据很容易
正如你所看到的，我们在GSL中有这个洗牌指令
在那里我们可以访问另一个线程的数据
让我们更详细地看看这些翘曲
所以硬件在这个三人组中处理威胁
三二威胁作为曲速
它们都有相同的指令指针
所以他们都做同样的指令
显然他们都有自己的寄存器
所以每个人都可以存储和读取自己的数据
但它们最终执行所有相同的指令
所以如果我们看循环
每个线程都有不同的循环计数
你知道我们运行循环和下一次迭代，我们发现好的
有些线程实际上已经完成了
然后硬件屏蔽这些线程
所以它实际上不会做计算
而是因为它们共享相同的指令指针
你知道这条线不能自己前进
这意味着如果你有一个非常
你知道
发散翘曲
其中一个循环真的很长
其他的都很短
所有其他威胁都不起作用
他们必须等待
如果你的分支是发散的，也是如此
所以如果一些线程在if中，其他线程在其他线程中
这意味着我们正在翻倍
我们必须连续执行这两个
好处是我们有这些指示
在那里我们可以轻松地在线程之间共享数据
就像一开始我们看到像素着色器
导数是
它可以很容易地访问其他威胁或数据来执行梯度指令
我星期三有个讲座
我在哪里进入这个问题
再详细一点
如何绕过它
Pierre已经提到了硬件会隐藏一些延迟
所以一些切换
所以这里有更多的细节
如果我们有一个翘曲
它有一些说明说
好的
我需要一些记忆
然后我们必须等待实际的记忆
硬件足够聪明地说
好的
这个曲速现在不需要做任何事情
只是在等待记忆
所以我切换到另一个曲速，这可能会有一些工作要做
所以我们你知道我们总是在这些翘曲之间切换
当没有人在等待记忆时，实际上没有人在等待记忆
这样有效的
计算时间得到改善
嗯
因为你知道，当硬件不等待内存时，我们总是让它忙起来
但你知道如果我们没有这么多线程运行
那么有时我们可能无法完全隐藏潜伏期
我们也受到了一点坡道的影响
所以它可能发生在我们没有的地方
嗯
我们不能完全隐藏潜伏期
因为我们不能在线程之间无限切换
你知道我们需要把目前的威胁状态存储在芯片的某个地方
当你写着色器时，这实际上是直接影响你的东西
因为这些片上资源主要是由着色器代码定义的
也就是寄存器用法
交叉身材阶段数据，因此从顶点到像素的传递等等
而且顶点输入属性，正如我们所看到的，在l one缓存中
就是你知道的
这个片上资源
所以让我们看看这里的一个例子，它有一些像素着色器输入
你知道很多数据来自顶点着色器
你知道的
如果你的像素着色器有一些动态分支，说
好的
我在用切线信息
当法线贴图处于活动状态时
嗯，这不是很好
因为你知道
那么我们总是有所有这些的全价
嗯
对于所有这些数据
创建专门的着色器要好得多
你说
好的
此代码只有在实际使用时才需要
所以有更多的着色器
因为链接器和整个
你知道驱动程序会扔掉着色器中不需要的所有东西
有时重新计算事情会更有效
所以在这个例子中，我们在一些向量上通过了物体空间和世界空间
继续使用对象空间并重新转换可能会更好
比如说
而不是发送所有的数据
主要适用于非常高的多边形场景，我们有
你知道很多很多的顶点
如果它们有这么大
那么我们就不能并行运行这么多顶点
然后我们无法隐藏潜伏期
因为我们没有那么多平行的东西
所以在那种情况下
这种优化有助于像素着色器也受益于一些
你知道的
我们实际上为你做的分组
所以编译器会发现
如果来自像素着色器的一大堆请求
并将它们分批
但是如果你有动态分支
那么编译器就不能真正批处理
因为您知道控件中有一些依赖项
所以它不能真的做到这一点
嗯，如果你有一些循环的动态
那么它也不知道你实际上有多少个循环
所以在这种情况下，当
尤其是当你必须解析着色器时
或者你知道任何一种图像处理，比如内核等等
那么您将使用编译时间循环
因为编译器实际上知道发生了什么
好的
嗯
对于内存类型
我们也有各种各样的
特别是缓冲区数据除外
我们有统一的缓冲
他们很适合
你知道
超快速统一接入
但它们不利于不同的访问
所以当一个线程再次做一些与另一个线程非常不同的事情时
它在同一个翘曲中
所以通常如果你做顶点皮肤
其中一个顶点有另一个骨基质
然后是另一个对均匀缓冲不好的
因为它会通过一条较慢的路径
嗯
一些动态变化
就像
如果数据
如果这里废话
那很好
因为所有的威胁仍然访问同一个地址
所以在分歧的情况下
最好使用纹理缓冲区
它们对仿制药很好
你知道读取操作
你还可以免费得到一些东西
就像地址数学
和一些格式转换，比如你可以使用
你知道吗
无符号字节被扩展为浮动之类的东西
我们还有着色器存储缓冲区
那就慢了一点
因为我们可能会做一些
你知道额外的着色器数学
当涉及到地址计算时
它是六十四位的
您还需要在着色器中自己进行转换
尤其是在火神星
不要检查健壮上下文标志
如果你不需要
因为在健壮的上下文中
我们也必须确保在着色器中检查越界
可以增加很多
可以将说明添加到
嗯
因为我们有这些不同的硬件单元
你知道的
如果你真的需要，只使用纹理缓冲区可能也不太好
如果你被这个内存盒的超级限制
因为所有的纹理缓冲区都会锤打纹理单元
也许你可以平衡
你知道的
两个着色器
存储缓冲区和纹理缓冲区
只是为了保持硬件的不同部分
好的
如果我们这么多关于着色器等等
那么硬件现在应该做的实际工作呢
最好的
你知道的
理想情况下，我们只做需要的工作
所以这真的是
嗯
你知道的
遮挡剔除对于很多大场景来说真的很棒
我们在过去和网络上
我们有实施非常有效的遮挡剔除技术的样本
所以我们只是减少工作量
它是围绕多画间接特性构建的
在Vulcan和OpenGL中都有
也是我们命令列表技术的一部分
在那里你知道
只需直接在GPU上修改That Draw参数
在这种情况下，你知道你会再次
当您在GPU上创建这些命令缓冲区时
你不会
你会想把它们压实
这样你就不会有管道气泡了
所以如果你知道
如果此命令缓冲区中的某些绘制调用设置为零
其中可以将计数和实例计数清除为零
穿过就会产生气泡
所以你想把东西压实
因为我们是
这特别棒
遮挡剔除
因为没有潜伏期
一切都在芯片上
最新的信息正在被使用
又不是说
也没有艺术品
所以它没有使用旧的遮挡信息
就像旧的方法
我们实际上在BR村有一个演示
有很多三角形的汽车模型
但你还是知道
以九十赫兹的速度运行
因为遮挡剔除
确保只显示所需的内容--另一种方法
这是这里最后一个话题
嗯
基本上
你知道
在我们扔掉一部作品之前
现在我们只是创建工作
我们需要的工作
我们需要的细节
很明显用镶嵌
你可以
你知道
自适应地创建三角形
你需要你需要的细节
嗯
它穿过这个
工作的重新分配
使硬件非常有效
可以创建补丁的子三角形
并再次将其分布在芯片上
所以一切都很有效率
所有的数据都被创建和产生
直接在片上存储器中生产和消耗
所以通过l 1和l 2缓存
所以一切都超级快
替代方案是几何着色器
当你有动态膨胀时，这就不太好了
所以镶嵌不应该用几何着色器来完成
因为我们必须预先分配所有的资源
而镶嵌着色器有这两个着色器阶段
在那里一个人说需要多少
然后用几何着色器执行
我们总是分配最大的
我们有一个快速的几何着色器，它的工作方式非常不同
这是一个允许非常基本的原始剔除的扩展
也喜欢多
你知道吗
以非常便宜的价格将相同的原语发送到不同的视图
但我们也可以做
你知道吗
只使用顶点着色器ID的程序效果
比如说
做一个GL
绘制数组并呈现许多原语
我们可以再次使用洗牌指令访问所有
我是说
在三角形内的不同顶点之间共享数据
你也可以自己取
这通常与间接平局齐头并进
你又有了结构
你定义你在GPU上实际需要多少
那么你实际上需要多少原语，多少三角形线
不管上一次
至少
您也可以使用像素着色器一点点来创建几何类型的效果
这将是蓝图渲染的一部分
星期三谈
嗯
我们在那里
你知道只要用一个丢弃物
你知道这样创建形状
缺点是我们需要自己计算覆盖率
因为你知道一个MS AA
只有三角形边缘才能给我们平滑的覆盖
然后如果我们在像素级别上制作这张卡
我们得自己计算
好的
我们有点过了时间
但是是的
这最终会发生
你知道我们在硬件上有很大的力量
还有很多很多的单位
所以理想情况下，你会发现哪些单位实际上是瓶颈
嗯然后你知道
尝试优化那些
理想情况下，您可以在芯片上保留尽可能多的数据
在芯片上更新它并找到
你知道吗
真的很酷
呈现事物和使用现代API机制的新方法
因为这可以让您远离CPU瓶颈
是的，是的
非常感谢
和